[Musique]
Jonas on a besoin de toi
on détecte une sur activité aquatique à
8000 mètres de profondeur dans la fosse
c'est un écosystème ancien et inexploré
ce qui se trouve là au fond tente de
remonter à la surface
c'était une mauvaise idée toute petite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Jonas on a de la compagnie
c'est le plus gros mec que j'ai jamais
vu le plus gros mec que quiconque a
jamais vu c'est le super prédateur
tout le monde rentre à la station vous
allez y arriver avancer
croisez énormément
j'espère que ce sera pas comme la
dernière fois
c'est passé la dernière fois
le vaut pas le savoir
[Applaudissements]
vous pouvez vous détendre cette station
elle est anti mec en fait c'est ce que
Jonas avait toujours redouté mais je
pensais
[Musique]